Travel he's got an omni side - who's he
gonna go easy on the slice comes out art
easy slice and dice onto your side
clockwork as well it's a team wide
secretive lost game - we're going to a
game three my friend showed me dude I
can still remember the guy who was kind
of playing other random custom games on
Warcraft 3 with I was initially I was
living in Singapore when I was like 15
14 years old I started playing like
random custom games on Warcraft 3 with
some of my school friends just in like
LAN cafes after school and stuff or on
weekends so that got me into Warcraft 3
then I kind of got into like the Walker
3 like classic melee mode and then one
day one of the guys I was playing was
like you have to try this game doe died
initially hated it like I knew was kind
of it was those very much.this just
feeling around it like it was so popular
and big at the time but it was just like
oh it's not like a serious game or it's
like a it's it's kind of like the newbie
I guess like the way dota place talk
about League was like the way my group
of friends gonna talked about dota then
cuz we all played Warcraft 3 which is
like the pure game I guess and dota was
just like a spin-off custom game so it
wasn't to be taken serious it is gonna
get the throne over this holy [ __ ] Kyle
might have lost game two I can't believe
or kind of getting into the Australian
team like as a manager in kind of I
guess I passed Irvine organised whatever
maybe I was actually playing I was
playing with the natural 9 guys I was
one of the I played the kind of four
position support role for the team so I
initially always just wanted to be one
of the pro players I was I guess that's
kind of how it started for a lot of
people just by either playing too much
casually for fun and then getting into
casting or playing in a kind of more
serious level that was always at least
somewhat a dream of mine
why did your appropriator not work out I
was kind of using dota as using my
University probably as a cover up for
attempting to play dota competitively
but I wasn't really going to classes I
was kind of struggling and then I ended
up moving on and kind of dropping my
studies for the time being which is when
I started working in juggling and that
was when dota 2 came out as well and I
was like okay I want to make a big push
with dota 2 I started playing with
natural 9 guys who were the best in
Australia who ended up actually gonna
ti2 so unfortunately I was juggling
trying to play with them and at that
point my parents stopped supporting me
because I wasn't at university I wasn't
studying anymore so I had to have a
full-time job so I was working in
restaurants bars trying to just feed
myself I still remember a time where I
would like go through all my pairs of
jeans to just try and find like a few
dollar coins - just like pay for a meal
or something and that was like what my
life was like at one point just because
of how much I just want to play dota I
wanted to really make it but I still
remember when the team talked to me I
was like look this isn't a workout like
you haven't got the time to commit we
also fight and in some ways also just
question my ability as well and my
ability commits the team and also my
ability as an individual player like I
think my performance suffered as a
result and they're like look we want to
try someone else out we think we can do
better with him and that kind of crushed
me at the time but obviously not
everyone can be a pro player there's a
lot of things that get in the way and
unfortunately it didn't work out for me
but it amazingly led to something else
which was just as good and challenging
so are you gonna see Zeus tweak your
necklace okay so I'm gonna stab you with
this like tea I like how suddenly like
busts out Alou never is like whoa house
is suddenly thinking Luna @ti in an
elimination match in Oh vici gaming or
winning with Luna I'll give you that
I'll give you that that's a good point
initially I was kind of organizing to
some small I guess you could call them
amateur tournaments but as far as the
Australian scene when it had all the
best teams just because there was like
not much prize money in it so I would
like kind of helped organize the
tournaments for the teams and people
want to watch it so I was like okay
let's this is when expert and twitch was
getting big so I figured I could just
easily make an account and started
streaming the games and
as someone who just had played a ton
competitively loved the game was just
addicted to the game - to be frank I was
like ok I want to talk about this and
people want to listen so I just started
going to casting I ended up joining
go-to gamers as one of their main dota
casters and they gave me a ton of
support helped get me to my first LAN
tournament Thailand as a dota caster and
about six months to a year later I
actually got offered a my first kind of
eSports job in Thailand where I was
based for about six months so I
Kickstarter I'm David Parker and I'm
David Gorman together we are beyond the
summit he on the summit was kind of just
like a placeholder name for I guess the
project and the old least initially was
maybe a more of a hobby but then it kind
of transitioned into this big kind of
project an idea of my where where I
wanted to do something to really help
grow the scene and be more involved
myself but also bringing other people
who had kind of similar goals ambitions
and LD was someone who had reached out
to me and kind of heard some good things
about he'd been counseling with luminous
over at dota commentary so I just took a
leap of faith and said okay you're from
the US you have a good streaming setup
you can assume like 720p as opposed like
the 480p or something we were streaming
in from Australia and said look want to
join me and be the official caster for
the TI to Eastern qualifiers here is
like prophet and morphing they just
cannot stop this push yeah and this is
what we talked about in the pregame is W
you don't really want to take white
people that was I guess the first time I
talked to LD and casted with him we
hopped into the first casts having never
even spoken together and that was just
kind of how things worked at the time
you just Skype in and say look mercury
Casca this is how it's going to work and
it was a great great experience i we
worked really well together and then
later that year we met at ti2 and
worked really well from their summit to
was when we had pool all kinds of
problems ahaha PC is not working in town
twerking pound org I don't know you the
list goes on that was like a disaster of
event for us that was more like we made
the resolution like we're not working
with a PC partner dead
we had like all these pcs provided and
like half um failed and then we had to
like luckily like I think Red Bull it
was like bailed us out like this brought
the trucks filled with some of their pcs
from their office town where like thank
God we can actually run an event now we
had all kinds of I think you do like
DDoS issues throughout the day like that
the stream was just a nightmare
everything about someone - it was a
rough of it though we made it through in
like teams they came back they trusted
us that look we're gonna fix everything
[ __ ] never again never again what we
do at an event like that I think by then
my parents were fairly accepting when I
finally relocated for BTS it was
probably the years preceding that where
they were very I guess non supportive of
the whole what I was doing
largely because they didn't I mean
partly because they didn't understand it
but lives because also I didn't
communicate what I was doing or
something I kind of I guess knew they
wouldn't initially accept so rather than
try and explain and prove them like this
matters a lot to me that I'm going to do
this it's going to be successful I said
I'm just going to do it and then they'll
have to learn to deal with it
the first Lanterman I went to and Tyla
even tell them I was going to Thailand
it happened to be like when I was like a
like bad storm coming or something and
they found on Facebook I was there and
they contact me like holy [ __ ] like your
entire like what the hell are you doing
like are you okay are you safe like so
it was I was angry him I was immature at
the time so um in hindsight that was
probably not the best way of approaching
it but I'm really happy we are
like my parents goes but when I first
the first tea I went to in 2012 my mom
was there and totally just said come and
come and see where this is and that was
around the time where they knew I was at
least somewhat serious about what I was
doing and it was starting to kind of
build up and become a thing that I could
just do more consistently I was getting
paid to do it so my mom saw me casting
or on the panel there in front of
thousands of people at Benaroya Hall and
she was kind of finally had I think bit
of a realization of like okay this is
not just a competitive gaming is a thing
like up until that point my parents had
no idea what it was I just knew I'm
broadcasting online and people are
watching and maybe I made some ad
revenue they at least understood that
this is what I was going to do so
whether I was going to succeed or not I
didn't even know I guess I was hopeful I
could I knew I wasn't gonna be a
complete failure but I didn't know for
something that was gonna last one year
five years ten years and I think my
parents would he was like they they they
had the same feelings but they were just
like well he's going to do it and they
were supportive at that point so next
for me I let's let's see where do I
wanna go thing I'd love to kind of be
able to dedicate more time to Vegas
personal growth as an individual outside
of dota I feel like so much of what's
defined me over the last two years it's
just being delayed but also I do want to
grow as caster as an analyst I feel like
there's a lot more I can learn about the
game and do within the game so I want to
challenge myself but I also want to make
sure that I continue to find that
balance so that I can also be I guess
maintained I guess maintain a decent
life balance and then be able to be more
productive and make sure that events
continue to go well for us